[Music]
here in this video we will present an
interesting list of the most powerful
humanoids from movies not the ones that
are humans or those that are not humans
but look exactly like us
like kryptonians or asgardians for
example
but just those that are somehow
representative of us in a way of body
structure but other than that they would
definitely look very different from us
so anyway humanoids let's get on with
this list
number 10 the alien species from the
movie species
this unnamed species is a very powerful
predatory race they track their origins
to the magellanic cloud and has been
described as a cancerous race
infiltrating other species gene pools
through breeding and other forms of
genetic contact they have skeletal
bodies with proportionately smaller
heads to their bodies
mouths having two hair like mandibles
and tentacle like hair they have the
ability to shape shift between human and
their alien forms they are highly
resilient to physical damage and can
regenerate at an extremely fast rate but
are still not invulnerable and can be
killed with sustained firepower and
flames
number nine gul'dan from the movie
warcraft he is the main antagonist of
that movie and is a very powerful
individual he is the founder and true
leader of the orcish horde
as the first orc warlock golden uses the
power of the fel to drain the life force
from his enemies and to corrupt and
twist his warriors into even more
terrifying forms as a warrior he is very
strong especially after his
transformation by the fel magic but he
was still physically weaker than durotan
the orc of the frostwolf clan however
what he lacked in brute strength he made
up for with near unlimited control of
the demonic fel magic
number 8 predator from the predator
series of films
these are an extraterrestrial species
characterized by their hunting of other
dangerous species for sport and honor
including humans the yalqia are a
sentient humanoid rays that breathe an
atmosphere similar to that of earth
but with a very high level of
technological advancement in their
civilization the predators talk and kill
their prey using a combination of highly
advanced technology such as active
camouflage and energy weapons combined
with primitive weapons such as blades
spears and nets
they are nearly impossible to kill by
humans and even hunt swamps of
xenomorphs for fun
number 7 the newborn from the alien
resurrection movie after the predator we
will now showcase one of the xenomorphs
although not the typical drone or queen
this entry is a human
xenomorph hybrid and is very well
humanoid in appearance it appeared to be
around twice as large as a standard
warrior and substantially stronger while
the newborn still possessed an elongated
skull it was far shorter and more human
in shape even its face looks like
slash human slash skull slash monster
even though it was still a baby at that
time it was able to tear off the head of
a queen xenomorph with a single swipe of
its hand imagine the power it will have
when it's all grown up
number 6 symbiotes from the venom movies
the symbiotes are a species of inorganic
amorphous symbiotic extraterrestrials
created from the living abyss
at the beginning of the universe by the
primordial deity the dark god called
null
these deadly parasites can fuse with
host creatures and merge with them and
these merged entities if compatible
would have extraordinary powers their
strength would be multiplied over many
times and would be highly resistant to
almost any type of weapons aside from
sonic and flamethrowers the best
examples of these symbiotes are venom
riot and carnage from the recent movies
and they are definitely more powerful
than the others we have just mentioned
before
number 5 sauron from the hobbit and the
law of the rings movies
this being is the main antagonist of the
free people of
middle earth for most of its history in
tolkien's works and definitely the only
dark lord during the events of the
hobbit and the lord of the rings he is a
corrupt admirer a being of immense power
can like angels sauron was also a shape
changer taking in one instance the form
of a serpent a vampire a great wolf but
in most cases a tall humanoid creature
clad in black armor
he has power over many things and his
magic is near unmatched he is the true
lord of the one ring and could only be
killed by the destruction of that
particular ring in mount doom number
four hellboy from the hellboy movies
also known as
rama and originally an offspring of the
fallen angel azil and a witch
meant to rule over the earth and bring
forth the fires of hell into this plane
of existence hellboy was instead adopted
from an early age by the bureau of
paranormal research and defense he grew
up fighting on the side of humans
against monsters and even though in his
normal form he is still way more
powerful than the strongest human ever
that is still not the true nature of his
being in his demonic form he is
absolutely hell incarnate he can change
his size to kaiju's scale control
lightning manipulate hellfire and fly
after sprouting draconic wings he is
indeed a powerhouse
number three thanos from the marvel
cinematic universe
definitely on the top three thanos is a
member of a race of aliens known as the
titans and is the most feared warlord of
the universe although in some theories
he isn't eternal
he is tall bulky and purple in color has
extreme endurance durability and a very
high intellect he is so powerful that he
could overpower the likes of captain
america with mjolnir thor with
stormbreaker and ironman in his nanotech
suit all at once he is definitely
stronger than even the hulk and could go
toe-to-toe with even captain marvel
without the infinity stones he is on the
third spot but with the six stones he
would definitely be number one
number two dark side from the dc justice
league movie seen in the zack snyder cut
of the justice league that was
re-released in 2021 darkseid is
definitely one to be feared once known
as auxas he is an ancient and
all-powerful cosmic new god warlord and
a conqueror who reigns over the fiery
extra-dimensional planet called
apocalypse and desires to rule earth and
the entire multiverse by harnessing the
unimaginable power of the anti-life
equation in his younger days he was
defeated by earth's forces which
included the old gods and a green
lantern but in the present time he was
in a league of his own another level
above steffenwolf a general of his army
who gave the justice league a run for
their money
and number 1 dr manhattan from the movie
the watchmen he was originally a human
but was transformed into a god-like
entity by an experiment gone wrong he is
shown to be absolutely powerful and
invulnerable to all harm even when his
body is disintegrated he can reconstruct
it in a matter of seconds
dr manhattan has complete awareness and
control over atomic and subatomic
particles and can even see neutrinos you
know light things something in physics
he is omni-kinetic which means that he
can do almost anything
he can teleport himself over cosmic
distances at will and perceives time in
a different way seeing the past present
and future
all at once he is indeed the most
powerful on this list
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam
[Music]